[Música]
eu estou aqui hoje pra lançar um desafio
para todos vocês
vamos todos nós juntos nos formarmos nos
maiores bem moleque dores de muros que
este país já viu
eu sei que isso pode soar meio estranho
time é irônico visto nosso contexto
mundial em que cada dia surgem idéias
cada vez mais esdrúxulas para separar
países povos e pessoas
mas vocês já pararam para pensar no
porquê a gente empilha pedras
nós construímos muros pra nos sentimos
protegidos para proteger uns quem ou que
esteja dentro daquele muro
nós construímos muros para nos sentirmos
seguros
antropologicamente falando naquelas ansa
para dar aquele quente no peito de que
eu tô separada de tudo aquilo que vai
ser diferente de mim e assim vamos
construindo muros e grandes obstáculos
entre nós há muito tempo criamos as
nossas zonas de conforto e definimos
aquele espaço como o espaço seguro que
me resguardar a de tudo que separa o eu
do outro do outro que é diferente de
tudo aquilo que eu acredito que nós
vamos construindo esses espaços e sempre
pensando em e me sentir longe e me
sentir mais tranquilo
criamos uma eterna de economia entre as
nossas casas ou seja nossos espaços
internos e as nossas cidades as nossas
ruas
os nossos espaços internos e usamos os
nossos muros como forma de
criar essa barreira entre nós desde
muito pequena eu sempre fui muito
curiosa sobre as formas que a gente
constrói as nossas cidades
sobre a forma que a gente dispõe as
nossas calçadas porque aquela rua é tão
tão estreita aquela rua é tão larga
porque esse poste está aqui não do outro
lado da rua porque eu queria um espaço
para bicicletas e não crie um espaço
ele queria um espaço para carros o
perdão e não cria um espaço para
bicicletas
então automaticamente não era de se
duvidar que eu ia virar uma urbanista e
com 20 e poucos anos em 2016 eu
resolvesse usar minha profissão para
estudar um pouco mais sobre essa nossa
dinâmica do medo né porque a gente tem
tanto medo da rua porque a gente coloca
grandes obstáculos na nossa frente
bom lá em 2016 quando eu resolvi de fato
estudar sobre isso eu comecei a
desenvolver uma pesquisa e outra em um
questionário com mais de 500 pessoas
entre homens e mulheres
para tentar entender porque é que nós
sentimos tanto medo de estar na rua e
por que que especial as mulheres sentem
mais medo de ocupar o espaço público
bom enquanto desenvolvia essa pesquisa e
conversavam um pouco mais com as pessoas
sobre sobre essas dinâmicas do medo de
fato eu também comecei a desenvolver
algumas algumas pesquisas também
voltadas mais para a questão histórica
no porque historicamente falando a gente
se construiu
dessa forma é importante a gente
entender que a nossa construção urbana e
arquitetônica forma que a gente dispõe
as nossas cidades
a forma que a gente dispõe os nossos
espaços ela está intimamente ligada à
forma que a gente dispõe a nossa
sociedade como um todo
a forma que a gente faz política a forma
que acho que os nossos cidadãos se
envolvem com as decisões
ana c políticas sociais do nosso país as
mulheres passaram a ter direito ao voto
no brasil em 1932 80 87 anos atrás
em 1962 foi promulgado o chamado
estatuto da mulher casada
nesse estatuto nós deixávamos de sermos
consultadas como tivemos um pequeno
truque apresentação aqui mas em 1962 é
com esse estatuto da mulher casada nós
passamos a deixar de ser consideradas
pelo estado brasileiro como civilmente
incapazes em 1962 57 anos atrás passamos
a ser consideradas civilmente capazes e
passamos a ser autorizadas a trabalhar
fora de casa
esse mesmo estatuto de 1962 eu repito
ano porque ainda é muito recente
as mulheres as mulheres cabia cabiam o
direito de zelar pela casa e pela
família hoje o estatuto dizia com as
seguintes palavras
cabe à mulher o zelo pela direcção moral
e material de sua família
apenas com a constituição de 1988 de 31
anos atrás
mulheres e homens passaram a ter os
plenos direitos iguais a todas as
mulheres sentadas nesta platéia hoje com
mais de 31 anos de idade
ao nascer tinham seus direitos
diferentes dos seus irmãos homens 31
anos atrás
toda a nossa construção política e
social no brasil ela esteve centrada em
mãos masculinas toda a nossa diversidade
política deixou de ser nunca foi muito
diversa ela sempre esteve concentrada
nas mesmas mãos nas mesmas
vivências a mulher cabia a
responsabilidade pela casa e pelo ar e
pela família e ao homem
a responsabilidade pela cidade e pela
rua
bom vocês devem imaginar que isso gerou
uma desenvolvimento histórico político
no brasileiro
muito focado em uma vivência única é eu
costumo eu costumo afirmar que nós
tivemos uma as nossas nossas relações
com a cidade elas estão diretamente
relacionadas às nossas vivências bom
naquela pesquisa que eu fiz em 2016
ao perguntar para as mulheres
qual era o relatório era a relação delas
com o espaço público eu perguntava para
as pessoas também
qual o medo elas sentiam já o qual o
qual insegurança elas sentiam com
relação a determinadas situações do
espaço público quando eu perguntei com
relação ao medo de ser estuprada nos
espaços públicos 59% das mulheres
disseram sentir medo incapacitante ou
pânico de serem estupradas
quando essa pergunta ela era adicionada
aos homens
imagino que não vai ser surpresa para
ninguém aqui o resultado era um por
cento dos homens diziam sentir medo
incapacitante o pânico de ocuparem os
seus espaços na cidade inteiramente é eu
apresentava algumas imagens e eu pedia
para que os os entrevistados
eles se sentissem e se imaginassem
naqueles espaços então apresentava
espaços que tinham características
urbanas muito claras
essa com a imagem que era apresentar
isso aqui é o que a gente claramente
como urbanismo a gente chama de beco né
e então estão a pesar são uma sanção
um espaços é travessias muito estreitas
com muros altos e apesar de uma curta
distância ainda são espaços muito
escuros bom quando apresentado isso
prazo para as mulheres 67 por cento
diziam sentir muito medo eu pedia para
que elas dissessem em uma escala de 1 a
5 sendo 1 o a área com muito medo e sim
com o espaço a resposta para medo nenhum
quando eu apresentar outras mulheres 67
por cento diziam sentir muito medo
para os homens a resposta de muito medo
ou seja escala 1 era de 42%
ao ser apresentado esta próxima imagem
em que a gente pode ver uma rua mais
larga mas também com a presença de muros
uma calçada mais estreita mas claramente
é uma rua ficada pra que o deslocamento
de veículos individuais
a gente vê que 45% das mulheres diziam
um é uma escala 4 de medo e 30% uma
escala 5 de medo ou seja 5 com muito
medo e quatro com um pouquinho menos de
medo mas ainda assim muito medo
apresentados aos homens a gente tinha
15% na escala 5 e 50% na escala 4
vocês podem ver que aqui a gente já
aproxima um pouco mais
apesar de ainda ter né somados 10% de
diferença mas ainda assim o entre os 5 e
14 uma diferença de gêneros quando
apresentadas imagens de espaços urbanos
mas o que é como a gente chama de mais
inclusivos e acolhedores
nós temos uma percepção que já muda um
pouco das pessoas nesse espaço por
exemplo temos calçadas largas a
vegetação é muito bem mais bem cuidada
as pessoas estão ocupando os espaços
urbanos e aí nesse caso nós temos 39 por
cento das mulheres dizendo sentir na
escala 1 de medo e 44% na escala 2
quando a gente passa para os homens a
gente tem 47% dos homens na escala é 2
por cento na escala 11 podem perceber
que cada vez mais é estas questões se
aproximam
eu gosto de comentar muito que que isso
aqui é claro eu acho que que é que fica
muito claro no momento em que a gente
insere espaços urbanos mais acolhedores
pessoas espaços urbanos em que elas se
sintam pertencente que elas se sintam de
alguma forma segura é a pequena
diferença que ainda se aproxima eu
atribuo ela a questões culturais
as nossas vivências anteriores porque o
nosso medo ele está diretamente
relacionado às nossas vivências tanto
nós quanto das pessoas próximas da gente
e essas vivências esses medos
eles também vão moldando a nossa forma
que a gente se relacione a nossa
segurança de manutenção de felicidade
nós não vamos ser felizes enquanto nos
sentimos inseguros e eu percebo que essa
essa relação de segurança e essa essa
apropriação do espaço pertencimento ao
espaço ele está diretamente relacionado
com a forma que a gente desenvolve os
nossos mecanismos de segurança porque
que nós construímos nossos muros porque
nós fazemos dessa forma é este
questionamento que eu quero trazer hoje
vocês acham que se as mesmas pessoas
sempre construir sem os mesmos espaços
estiverem sempre estivessem sempre
presentes nos mesmo é meio de decisão
nós faríamos da mesma forma nós
construiremos muros tanto físicos quanto
metafóricos tantos muros entre nós o que
o que trago hoje pra vocês é a sensação
de que se a gente acolhesse diferentes
diversidade se a gente acolhesse
diferentes vivências nós resolveríamos
nossos problemas relacionados à proteção
da mesma forma todos nós concluímos no
medo
isso é inegável todos nós temos medo de
andar na rua hoje em dia
a insegurança urbana ela é um senso
comum para todos é um problema para ser
resolvido para todos mas a partir do
momento que nós consideramos uma única
vivência para tomar todas as decisões
nós estamos realmente escolhendo as
melhores soluções se a gente começasse a
conversar com maior uma maior
diversidade a gente começasse a incluir
pessoas com vivências diferentes nós nos
nas áreas de decisão nós faríamos da
mesma forma
hoje em dia apenas 1% das terras globais
estão sob a posse de mulheres 1% de
acordo com o autor calling no seu livro
de feição filme anuais
a gente não pode estimar que o único
ponto de vista um conto um ponto de
vista puramente masculino ele possa
realmente tomar as decisões que sejam
melhores para todos nós temos que
considerar cada vez mais diferentes
pontos de vista
bom a minha proposta que hoje é que a
gente seja não seja radical eu não acho
que a gente vai ser eficiente se a gente
de fato empunhar marretas e sair batendo
nas bases de todos os altos muros que a
gente vê por aí
eu acredito que a gente deve de jolo em
tijolo e deve o primeiro passo que a
gente vai alcançar é de fato começar a
dialogar é começar a acolher o diferente
é falar sobre sobre as questões e
debater e co criar juntos novas soluções
para a gente resolver o problema da
insegurança urbana
nós precisamos conversar nós precisamos
debater e nós precisamos estar sempre
atentos ao olhar do outro sempre atentos
à questão de como cada um vai ver a sua
cidade como cada um pode proporcionar
uma nova uma nova alternativa
para a gente resolver os nossos nossas
inseguranças
a proposta aqui é que a gente trabalhe
de tijolo em tijolo como eu falei se
trabalharmos com marretas o resultado
seria trágico o peso de um sistema que
mesmo que falido como é o sistema da
desigualdade que é o sistema que rege as
nossas relações políticas urbanas ainda
hoje no brasil ele ele ainda é muito
pesado e ele ainda rege muitas relações
a gente não pode esperar que a gente vai
discutir para demolir esse sistema e
sistema injusto de um dia para outro
sistema pouco diverso de um dia para o
outro
a gente tem que começar a trabalhar de
tijolo em tijolo no começo vai aparecer
muito demorado porque o muro é muito
alto os nossos muros entre nós e eles
ainda são muito altos mas a gente
precisa começar a vislumbrar novas
soluções
nós precisamos acolher diversos nós
precisamos ocupar os espaços urbanos
nós precisamos x nos unir em novas
soluções e de tijolo em tijolo se cada
um de nós for tirando um pouco dos seus
tijolos
aos poucos vai dar pra gente começar a
ver a vista por trás do muro e os ventos
da mudança os ventos da inovação que nós
falamos tanto hoje em dia eles vão poder
comprar novamente obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]